who's in charge in sri lanka the
president has fled instead of resigning
the acting leader has imposed a curfew
but protesters want him to step down as
well is there a way out of the crisis to
prevent a power vacuum this is inside
story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
daddy in abu gheda sri lanka's political
turmoil is deepening president gotapaya
rajapaksa had promised to resign by
wednesday but instead he's fled to
singapore via the maldives the acting
president ranel wikramasinga has
declared a nationwide curfew the army
has been cleared to use force if
necessary to maintain order sri lankans
say these developments are unacceptable
protesters have decided to leave the
government buildings they've occupied
since saturday but they're adamant their
campaign will continue until both
rajapaksa and wikramasingha are out of
office
for people
because of
everything lost
everything lost
all the
places
fighting fighting because of poor money
that's why the pope too much problem
that's why these people who want
god
go
home then
new government
people government a lot of corruptions
over here uh with them
without them no corruption will be ahead
came to power saying he would solve
problems but look what has he done he's
not done anything look at what happened
yesterday not even women were spared
during election time they came and
embraced people and made all sorts of
promises but they haven't delivered any
of them so there is no point in renewal
or gotham they have to go
stefan has more from colombo
[Music]
after occupying this building they are
going to leave the president's house now
the protesters are making announcements
they're shouting slogans they say after
these five days we've made our point and
now we're going to regroup and continue
our protest elsewhere it has never been
our goal to occupy government buildings
they occupied it since saturday when
more than 200 000 protesters stormed the
residency of the president here this old
colonial building but also the
secretariat of the president the prime
minister's house and also yesterday the
office they will empty all these
premises they will keep a rallying
ground near the president's secretariat
but they also said what happened on
wednesday violence at the parliament
people storming parliament that was
never our intention and they do now want
to regroup and they're still asking for
uh president
to officially resign and if not they
want parliament to impeach him or
abolish his executive powers and they're
also calling still for the acting
president to step down immediately
president still has not sent his
resignation as you know the prime
minister first says he's not the acting
president then he says is the acting
president so what the the tactic of our
rulers have been to create discord
amongst protesters and amongst people
here and to create disharmony and create
violent incidents but that is not what
the original people who came here and
the people who came here with the july
9th
event demanded and wanted of course
there would be various elements coming
here trying to create discord but we
will always try to keep them out we will
always fight against violent elements
because this has always been a peaceful
struggle in the past couple of days
thousands and thousands of sri lankans
have visited this residence of the
president you've seen probably the
images of people jumping into his pool
and also sitting working on his in his
fitness area but the protest movement is
a coalition a very broad coalition of
very different
groups and they're very worried that
there will be some splintering some some
cracks
happening and that's why they're now
regrouping they're packing up this stuff
here at the residence of the president
and they will continue the rally
somewhere else but they really hope now
that parliament takes the lead in uh
impeaching or abolishing executive
powers of president gotabaya rajapaksa
[Music]
let's bring in our guests all in colombo
joining us from there is khabir hashem
who's a member of the parliament with
the main opposition and a former
minister jihan pereira is the executive
director of the national peace council
of sri lanka and harshana nanayakara is
a lawyer and member of national people's
power that's an opposition coalition
welcome to the program thanks so much
for your time johan pereira who's in
control of the country
the
who's in control it is the
government is in control but uh
it is a tenuous control because
the government has lost its legitimacy
it has a majority in parliament it has
the powers of the presidency
but the people's people have nullified
it nullified that mandate by their
by the peaceful revolution that took
place where the president had to flee
the country so in a way it's a very
unsettled situation it is not stable
problems are not being solved problems
are massive in the country
the lines fuel lines are extraordinarily
long two or three kilometers people are
staying two three days three four days
uh waiting for petrol overnight in their
vehicles the prices have doubled
people's uh stand up living has
collapsed
and yet our leaders are not taking
action they are not settling their
problems among themselves and cohesively
coming up with a economic plan for the
revival of the country okay
we're going to get on to these issues in
a moment but first let me bring in kabir
hashem to tell um to tell us who you
think is in control of the country and
whether there's a power vacuum going on
right now
um well i think in a sense the people
were in control for a while um and now
there is a lack of
uh sanity actually and it's about time
that sri lanka got on its way so
uh it's it's about not only the
legitimacy of the government it's about
credibility of the government people
have lost faith lost trust
and therefore uh right now
parliament uh the opposition including
all other political parties met together
yesterday today and we
we have asked for time that is meeting
with the speaker of parliament tomorrow
where the leaders of
almost all political parties will meet
the speaker and ask him to call summon
parliament where we would be able to
appoint a prime minister
amongst us a consensual uh prime
minister and then to appoint the
president so we are trying to work
towards that to have a
unity government for a period to
stabilize the country because there are
lots of reforms that have to take place
okay just on the issue of the succession
plan on the issue of this succession
plan kabir hashem i mean is this going
to be an easy task you say that there's
a there's a meeting tomorrow what are
you expecting to come out of it yeah
yeah
it will be made much easier if gotham
rajapaksa has submitted his letter of
resignation by now to the speaker which
he has said but we haven't seen the
letter so if the president has submitted
his letter of resignation then there is
an automatic process where the
parliament can choose a president the
same way the prime minister
can be appointed if there is a majority
in parliament who supports the prime
minister so right now we think that
opposition and the other parties working
together can have that majority to get a
prime minister that represents the
majority in parliament and then amongst
us to appoint a president and then have
any a government that will take us
through the reform process and stabilize
the economy to a point and then maybe go
for an election at a particular time so
it is not difficult because the system
is very much intact the constitution has
provisions on how to do it the question
is that we haven't seen the president's
letter yet and if that doesn't happen by
tomorrow then that certain element of
answer yeah that's exactly it
that's exactly it let me bring in
harshana at this point because um as
uh kabir was just saying under the
constitution it's the prime minister who
steps up as acting president if the
president resigns but since we haven't
seen the president's resignation how
uncertain
is the path ahead
well it's like this
right now as kabir pointed out he has
not resigned we have not seen the letter
and also ranil claims that he's been
appointed as the acting
president
but no one has seen the warrant issued
by the president to that defect in fact
there has to be a seal and an emblem
there's a procedure
for him to be acting as a president and
also it cannot be for an indefinite
period the warrant should state for how
long he is going to be the prime
minister for so with none of those
formalities have been
uh followed or at least we do not know
of
the problem remains with even the prime
minister acting as the president is
valid in that case all the orders he
issues in the acting capacity
are unlawful and could even amount to
treason
okay so therefore right now there's a
huge problem whether ronnie is even
appointed as acting prime minister
so this is exactly the reason why that's
turmoil on the streets and unrest
because people just do not know what's
going on around so i am of the view in
the absence of them showing it the
warrant of execution which comes in
official letter witnessed by the
presidential secretary
that it is not available this
constitutional crisis
and the uncertainty and the instability
will continue okay
we have a situation now right we have a
situation now where the prime minister
has been issuing orders for example he's
ordered the army to use force if
necessary that's one of the things that
he's come out with and seeing as the
prime minister was also is considered
the president's deputy in parliament
but with him being deeply unpopular as
we know in sri lanka where does this all
leave things
well i mean this is exactly what i'm
trying to say therein because
people do not trust this government they
do not trust russian diplomacy okay the
slogan is go to rajapaksa go home run in
vikram and singa go home and none of
them have resigned now he is claiming to
be acting as
the president claiming because i have
not seen that lawful authority he has on
paper but then he should be appointing a
prime minister so he can't be acting as
prime minister and president both
because he's supposed to appoint a prime
minister from his cabinet which he has
not done so there is a crisis
as khabir was pointing out earlier
if
gotab does not give this letter of
resignation and follow the
constitutional process from tomorrow
onwards it will escalate and even the
trade unions and the country would go
for island by general strikes as you
know our life has already been crippled
lack of fuel lack of income
shortages of food so it will only
escalate simply because uh the the
president has not given his resignation
and neither is being appointed so it
will continue to destabilize right and
get into
really bad levels
johan even if um there's this meeting
taking place tomorrow as we as we've
been hearing uh from from kabir
um even if they come up with some sort
of consensus agreement the members of
parliament is that something that the
public is going to accept because at the
end of the day doesn't it risk a lot of
the same faces just staying in in these
positions for at least this period
yeah well i mean what what the people
have been asking for the civil society
the bar association the religious clergy
is a all-party
in government
because we have to be governed by
someone so an all-party interim
government uh selected by consensus
which would steer the country out of its
present predicament over the next six
months perhaps
deal with the imf deal
find a solution to some of the problem
pressing problem the most pressing
problems of shortages
and then go for elections i think people
would accept that what the people don't
want is this rajapaksa government
uh even if the rajapaksa are not there
physically it's they're still there in
spirit they don't want that to continue
that's what they have been revolting
against in large numbers
unified that's a unified sense among the
people that this government must go
right but the the the issue for a lot of
people the way that i understand it is
that they are concerned by what's called
political corruption in the country
jihan that has been taking place for uh
for many many years so to what extent
has this political corruption deepen the
mistrust
in governments as a whole
yeah i mean what has happened is that
people are blaming this government and
this leadership and the rajapaksa family
in particular but while as you say it is
something that also comes from the past
it is not just this government and this
leadership that has been corrupt but
previous governments and previous
leaderships also have been corrupt and
have to take part of the responsibility
but this government in particular was
particularly blatant about it they had a
sense of entitlement president as soon
as he came to power when he won the
election in 2019
arrogated to himself the powers of more
powers from parliament and then
proceeded to make some terrible
decisions that has immediately declared
tax cuts for the rich and then he went
into banning for chemical fertilizers
and trying to make sri lanka organic
farming country overnight
and basically and and also the the
corruption the incredible corruption so
that people
people really believe the people on the
street believe
that the government leaders actually
hearted dollars in cart in container
container loads of dollars per cent out
of the country and that is why we don't
have foreign foreign exchange in our
country right so the blame comes solidly
on this government even though previous
governments are also responsible for the
predicament we are in kabir um is the
priority now to get
politics back on track or the economy
i think both have to be done parallelly
because to win you need to win political
credibility and trust and economic
credibility and trust so we would have
to
listen to the sounds coming from the
ground from the protesters and we have
to do some constitutional amendments
more accountability more transparency
more
action against corruption
do we have to win that confidence so the
new consensus government will have to
make those moves in the first few months
so that we win
the people have confidence and then we
need to do for over 20 to 30 years we
haven't done economic reforms that is
why we came here apart from the
corruption we have to take a lot of we
have to make a lot of changes fiscal
speaking of changes speaking of changes
let me ask you particularly about one
political change and that is the 20th
amendment as you know which was passed
in 2020 that really reconcentrated power
uh in the presidency itself as a member
of the opposition now is that something
that the opposition is going to look to
abolish
of course we have already given a draft
uh bill to parliament calling it the
21st amendment and that entails
the aspirations of what the country has
been asking for in the last couple of
months unfortunately some of the
government members have come up with an
alternative which is uh 22nd amendment
which doesn't go that far so we are
trying to come to a compromise to go
back at least to the 19th amendment
which was there before where the
president's powers are stripped to a
large extent we want it to go further
people want the abolition of the
presidency we want to move to that so we
are going to go as far as we can for for
what the people are asking for their
aspirations so that will be the first
step political credibility
then will be established in the country
but parallel we need to work with the
imf and get the reform process going
and restructure the debt i think we can
do that speaking of the imf harshana
how difficult are negotiations going to
be with the imf going forward because
sri lanka is now going into these
negotiations as a bankrupt country
well things are going to be hard and
difficult but there's no doubt that we
will need to seek third party health
there's no doubt about it but it all
depends negotiations are going to be
difficult as you know as a bankrupt
nation our bargaining powers are limited
whether you go to imf or any other place
they will look
to impose conditions
so that the country will be more
accountable lack of accountability on
the part of our governments has been the
biggest curse the corruption came as a
result of that so it's going to be tough
road ahead and we need
unity in approach remember as the two
members said earlier
initial job is for an interim government
for a limited period to get the most
essential
that is the cooking gas full so the
country can function and fertilizer for
the farmers and to open the schools
which are being closed indefinitely now
this is going to be the task
for
the interim government the main task but
they will have to start negotiating and
opening up channels and discussing and
going for forensic audits to see what
happened to investments that openness is
necessary so therefore
the first three months or four months or
six months the limited period we have to
address these
issues
but thereafter or parallelly as kabir
would put it we have to battle the rest
of the negotiations it's not going to be
easy it's not going to be easy we are a
bankrupt nation
with so much debt right and when the imf
goes into
when the imf gives bailouts as you know
uh harshana the the bailouts come with
uh with
austerity which generally affects the
poor and the people you're right you're
right that's how they have got and
wherever emf has gone there has been
some on occasion change of governments
but here what is important is the
negotiation when they ask for austerity
measures we are not supposed to cut down
health and education but all the perks
these corrupt politicians and members of
parliament are having so there are
places we can shave off there are places
we can cut off without
touching the poor masses because after
the corona virus closed down and after
the economy coming to unhaul i mean if
you try to cut off things from the
people obviously there's going to be
turmoil okay let me bring in jahan jahan
um um what are the
uh obviously the immediate priorities is
to get food fuel and medicine uh for for
the people and um how do you think it's
all going to play out uh with the imf
negotiations johan as well as
countries like india and china who have
stepped up in a way or provided loans to
sri lanka up at this point
in india in particular has been very
generous to sri lanka it has given about
3.5 billion dollars over the last
several months to us in term in credit
lines and it is the ending of that
credit line that has created this
enormous fuel crisis in our country
the imf
negotiations and the
plan that and the actions that sri lanka
will have to take off that will be very
difficult ones to take and that is why
we need a government that people can
trust that people can trust and which
can go to the people and explain to them
because
there'll be a lot of
major reforms needed for instance our
public service
is
one million strong with the armed forces
is 1.4 million for a population of 22
million our defense budget is 15
i mean double that of health and
education
combined i think so that there's need
for those type of reforms that can be
done but which will be difficult and we
don't need a very courageous
government a bold government which will
have to think more of the country than
of their of than of themselves and their
own futures
and be trusted by the people
yeah that is the key thing to gain uh
trust once again kabir in your opinion
what are the
most immediate steps that need to be
taken in order to
leave the pressure off the suffering of
the people
yeah people believe that uh the shortage
of oil and gas petroleum products are
the key problem but that's only a
symptom of the the main issue the main
issue is solvency the lack of dollars we
don't have the money to import any of
this so what we need to do is to do the
sustainability that restructuring
process as fast as possible by end of
this year timelines if you look at it
imf you should be able to get the
uh
executive board to approve the
external fund facility
which is about three billion dollars
before the end of this year then go for
the rapid financing instrument and then
for the interview we need to find some
uh funding as bridging finance so sri
lanka are managed in december if we do
that and if we do if we go into the
restructuring successfully confidence
builds up and then sri lanka starts
easing out of the problems so that that
is the critical thing but also talking
about since you are raised about the
poor the austerity measures imf also
will support us with cash transfers to
the poorest of the poor because you
can't
do without that you need to help the
poor because they're in very difficult
position over 40 percent i think are
falling into the poverty line now so we
would also be
have to do some cash transfer measures
whilst we do the reforms uh fast so this
means talking the truth there is no easy
way out government has to start telling
people exactly that it's not going to
finish in three months or six months
it'll take some time but we are taking
the right measures that's critical
talking the truth to the people is very
important and i think sri lanka can do
it the resources
okay harshana final words to you i mean
we're talking about how to gain trust of
the people of sri lanka but how does the
country begin to win back the
international credibility and trust
i mean international credibility as the
lowest ev now
again as kavi was putting it there are
no shortcuts to bring credibility but
openness accountability
and dealing as an unaligned nation
without selling ourselves to just one
country with the china or otherwise
and we have to build up that confidence
and all this will start only after a
fresh election with a new parliament
right now this parliament is not trusted
not believed and i'm sure in another
election most of these members won't
even be returned to the parliament by
the public we have to wait and see so
trust building first
is locally the people must trust their
government
and once they start trusting the
government people will work economy will
function and of course we have to guide
it correctly without winning the
credibility of the public here
international community is not going to
consider any government here as a
legitimate country okay for the sake of
time let me just jump in there we have
30 seconds remaining last question to
you in fact and that's on the issue of
accountability how do the people of sri
lanka get accountability from their
leaders
so far accountability has been focused
on on the issue of what happened during
the war human rights accountability war
crimes issues but now we also have to
deal with
accountability issues relating to
economic crimes
running down the economy robbery
corruption so i think people are now
more prepared for that and in terms of
ethnic conflict this this crisis has
actually brought all our people together
right on the streets are similar is
tamils and muslims and and they say we
will not be deceived again by leaders
who try to divide us in order to get our
vote okay thank you so much i'll have to
leave it there on that note thanks for
joining us kabir hashem jihan pereira
and harshana nanayakara
thank you for watching you can see the
program again anytime by visiting our
website al jazeera.com and for further
discussion you can always go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story join the
conversation on twitter our handle is aj
inside story from myself and the whole
team bye for now
[Music]
you